en Turquía a pesar de la prohibición de
marchar en muchas partes del país miles
de mujeres se reunieron en Estambul las
manifestantes tuvieron que esquivar la
policía que mantenía cerrados los
accesos a la famosa Plaza taxin
venimos aquí para mostrar nuestra rabia
contra el estado y para mostrar su
irresponsabilidad con respecto al
feminicidio También estamos aquí juntas
por las personas que perdimos a causa
del terremoto El feminicidio y los
asesinatos de transexuales
en Pakistán miles marcharon en las
principales ciudades en contra de la
violencia de género pese a los intentos
de las autoridades por impedir estas
reuniones
para mí el derecho que debería estar en
primer lugar es el derecho a elegir
deberíamos tener derecho a tomar
nuestras propias decisiones ya sea el
matrimonio el divorcio la elección de
una carrera la decisión de estudiar o
cualquier otra decisión en nuestras
vidas estoy aquí para todos estos
derechos en este país las marchas son
criticadas por promover los valores
liberales occidentales e ir en contra de
la religión algunos temas como el
divorcio el acoso sexual o la
menstruación siguen siendo tabú mientras
que en kabul unas 20 mujeres salieron a
las calles y desafiaron el régimen de
los talibanes el día anterior varias
mujeres se habían reunido a puertas
cerrada para reclamar el regreso de sus
derechos y la reapertura de las escuelas
para las jóvenes
sin quedarnos en casa nos lleva al cielo
Entonces no quiero ir allí mientras
creen tantas restricciones sobre que
llevar y cómo llevarlo si un hombre que
te mira no debe sentirse tentado
Entonces porque los hombres no se cubren
los ojos según las Naciones Unidas desde
el regreso del régimen talibán
Afganistán es el país más represivo del
mundo hacia las mujeres